IAN LAKE: So there I was,
building a great responsive UI,
when it hit me.
Multi-Window is going
to change everything.
Well, OK.
Maybe not everything.
But there are some
special considerations
when it comes to
building and designing
for Split-Screen Multi-Window.
Now, one thing
that hasn't changed
is the importance
of a responsive UI.
A responsive UI is one that's
able to adapt to the space
available.
So some of the same techniques
you've used before just
become even more important
when users can resize your app.
Check out our other video on the
basics of building a responsive
UI and the patterns you can use
to adapt your layout to changes
in size.
Thankfully, building
a responsive app
for your existing
users covers almost all
of the configurations you'll see
in Split-Screen Multi-Window.
But there are two relatively
unique configurations
you might consider when
designing your app.
First is the 16 by 9 layout
on mobile devices in portrait.
Here it's important to keep in
mind the heavily constrained
vertical space.
Make sure users can
actually see some content
between fixed navigation
elements, like an expanded app
bar, and bottom navbar.
The others is the 34.15%
layout on tablets.
Here you have an extremely
wide aspect ratio
on portrait devices.
A technique we've
found useful is
to start with your
mobile device layouts
and stretch them to fit
this new configuration.
Once you have a
fully responsive UI,
now comes the fun part, taking
advantage of Multi-Window.
By default,
Multi-Window is enabled.
And it's enabled for
your entire task stack.
That means if your root
activity supports Multi-Window,
every activity started from
that root activity also
needs to support Multi-Window.
This also applies to any
exported activities you have.
They'll inherit the Multi-Window
capabilities of the other app
and therefore should always
support Multi-Window.
Now, when in Multi-Window
mode, the minimal size
is 220 by 220 dp.
You can use minheight
and minwidth
to set a larger minimum
size, but in Split-Screen
Multi-Window, users can
still resize you smaller.
You'll just get cropped off.
And no one likes an
inaccessible button.
So try removing as
much as possible
to get down to
that minimum size.
Now, beyond the
first priority of,
does my app run in
Multi-Window mode,
it should come as no surprise
that the best experience
here for users is the
fast, smooth transition
from the biggest screen
sizes, down to the smallest,
and vice versa.
If your tablet or mobile
layouts are very similar,
you may find this to
already be the case.
The important thing
to remember is
you don't want the user to feel
lost when they resize your app.
If your layouts are
vastly different,
don't change between them.
Instead, try scaling
your tablet UI down
to fit the smaller space.
That way your app will be
consistent on all sizes.
Keep in mind that just like
any other configuration change,
the default behavior is to kill
and recreate your activity when
it's resized, reloading all
of your resources for you.
Assuming you save your state
using onSaveInstanceState
and use loaders or
other techniques
to keep data across
configuration changes,
this should be really fast.
However, if you want
to take total control
and reload only the
exact things you need,
you can handle configuration
changes yourself
by adding the configChanges
attribute to your activity
and then applying the changes
in onConfigurationChanged.
Not for the faint
of heart though.
Test thoroughly.
Now, if you're a fully immersive
experience like a game,
I get it.
Maybe you want to
disable Multi-Window.
If you aren't targeting API
24, adding Android orientation
or Android immersive
to your manifest
will disable Multi-Window.
And, of course, the new
resizableactivity attribute
can be added to your application
or to your root activity
to opt out of Multi-Window.
Check out the blog post
linked in the description
for all the details,
and some other patterns,
like relying on edge swipes,
that should be avoided
to best support Multi-Window.
Build a great responsive UI.
Build a great
Multi-Window experience.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]